this might be the craziest fun fact
about any comedian period Rick Glassman
played in two high school basketball
games against LeBron James during the
years of 2001 and 2002. during their
second matchup Rick even brought a copy
of the now famous Chosen One LeBron
magazine cover for the king to sign
after the game it was two days before he
was on the cover of Sports Illustrated
of which I bought and brought to have
him sign as if good game good game good
game After High School both Rick and
LeBron have gone on to continue playing
basketball with Rick Glassman playing
pickup from time to time and LeBron
growing up to become the NBA's all-time
leading scorer